remember I was at State College and I
didn't like the hotel room okay not that
I'm a Diva but it's like I'm not staying
here on the phone with Burr and I go hey
man I'm sorry just give me a second and
he goes what's wrong I go this room's
terrible and Bill goes You Know listen
man you're making moves you're coming up
go to another hotel I go yeah and you
know what you're right and I put my bag
down and I'm about to get off the phone
with him we got into an argument about
Montana Brady this is when Brady had
three or four rings okay and we got into
an argument Montana Brady screaming at
each other I'm not this is I'm not
exaggerating screaming at each other in
this hotel room I hated for three hours
that it got too late I had to stay there
I couldn't even I couldn't even check in
I couldn't even check in I had to stay
because of the lunacy that went on the
insults the screaming and I stayed in a
horrible hotel room because I yelled
with him for three hours and I assume
you took the Montana side of it no you
took the Brady side he was being a
contrary he said you can't say that yet
you know Montana went to four one four
did not bring it up to Bill that you're
you're right all along when he when he
got to like six or seven I was like are
we gonna do this anymore